So, you might have noticed that I
preemptively added a little Edit Name
button in the Menu Bar.
If you click on it,
the Edit Name dialog pops up.
Now that you know more about Firebase's
four write methods, can you add the code
so that the app actually updates
the name of the Firebase shopping list?
Here, I'll show you what I mean.
Right here is the Edit List
button that I was talking about.
When you press it, it'll show a dialog.
You should be able to type
the name in here, and
then press Edit Name to edit
the name of the shopping list.
Shopping lists contain a few properties,
and
right now the listName is the only one
that we're making directly editable.
The name of the owner will not change.
Right now the owners are all
named anonymous owner,
which is rather ominous sounding, but
we'll worry about fixing that when we
add user accounts in the next version.
Now the timestampLastChanged
property is interesting.
It should update whenever we
change any part of the list, so
when we change the listName,
timestampLastChanged will be modified,
but it won't be directly
modified by the user.
So, when we change the listName,
timestampLastChanged should also change.
It's worth noting that, in the future,
this area will contain a list of items
in the shopping list, but
that will come later in this version.
Right now,
just focus on making the name and
the timestamp change using the right
methods we just talked about.
I'll send you a full spec right now.